[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture on strain energy
we had
obtained this expression that sigma i j
is equal to del u naught
del epsilon i j and after obtaining this
expression we had
pose the question whether it is possible
to obtain
this kind of a an expression for
the epsilon i j counterpart expression
for the
epsilon i j in terms of the sigma
ij so we had ended with this motivating
question so the answer is yes it is
possible to find such an
expression and such a relation uh and
the answer of course
is what this this complementary energy
is
so uh what we are going to do is
we are going to uh answer this question
uh
in a slightly uh mathematically abstract
way
what we are going to do is we are going
to ex
to to define a complementary
energy density
we are going to uh define it
to this expression
so this u naught with a dash that is the
complementary energy density
and we are going to define it
in this fashion
now just written outright like this it
uh
it may seem a little bit alien
but the idea behind this is something
very general mathematically
which is actually referred to as the
legendary transformation okay
so it is not just in the context of this
kind of
uh of the complementary energy density
that we that we come up with legendary
transformation
rather uh in in many different areas in
uh for example in thermodynamics
as well as in other areas we whenever
deriving these kinds of mathematical
frameworks where we wish to find out
these kinds of counterpart expressions
we we appeal
to the use of uh of the legendary
transformation
all right so uh so how can we
uh so so what do we what we want to
prove here uh
to prove that uh this indeed provides us
with the answer that we are seeking here
so we wish to show or we
wish to prove that epsilon i j
is equal to del u naught
dash l sigma i j
this is what we want to prove let's see
if we can indeed
prove this we'll start
with this expression
and very naively we'll proceed by just
trying to take the partial derivative of
this left hand side
with respect to sigma i j so basically
we're just going to write down this
on the right hand side similarly we have
to carry out the partial derivative
now for this because we have two terms
multiplied
we are going to use the chain rule to
break them apart so
all right next we note that so the left
hand side
it doesn't undergo any change but this
right hand side we can do a little bit
of manipulation
for this first term and write it in this
fashion
now please note that what i have written
here is quite illegal
in the sense of in the sense of the
index notation as we have learned in our
applied elasticity
so what i should actually do is just
write down this epsilon i j in terms of
the p
cube
all right now this term
so this is the kind of term which we
have encountered previously in our
discussions of applied elasticity
and the answer to it is simply obtained
by noting that
we can we can use the substitution power
of the chronicle delta
to obtain this
so this is
okay now this epsilon pk remains as it
is
pq remains as it is and this term also
remains as it is
so i need to make a little bit of space
here let me see if i can do that quickly
i think that should do it all right
so continuing uh
this particular thing uh you please note
that it is exactly in this form del u
naught del epsilon i j
except that in place of i j i have p pq
so
this can be written as minus sigma pq
this part just remains as it is
plus this uh p gets
substituted by this i and this q also
gets substituted by this j
so i have epsilon i j
and plus of course this term which which
remains as it is
and now you can see that this last this
first term
it cancels this last term so overall
what we are going to have
is that this thing is just going to be
equal to epsilon i j
if i write that in my next
page del u dash del sigma i j
is equal to epsilon i j so this is what
we had to prove and we have
we have just proved it okay
so
it's proved
now what's the implication of this
so uh all this talk about the legendary
transformation
and the and the rewriting uh
of the expressions is fine
mathematically but
what is the usefulness of this well you
see
what we have just described in terms of
the complementary energy
that is exactly what is going to lead us
to a discussion
of the all important uh of
castigliano and i say all important
because
the main activity which will result
from this all these uh sophisticated
rather sophisticated discussions
of this energy methods where we are
bringing together mechanics
uh concepts from thermodynamics and so
many other
mathematical things uh ultimately
we wish to solve uh certain problems
up using this energy methods and you
will see that
the ultimate basis of those will be the
use of this
uh complementary energy to the so of
course the application of the
castigliano's theorem which will be
discussing
sometime later now uh
before we go into those sorts of
discussions uh
i i wish to point out one important
thing
so you see uh we have motivated this
definition of the complementary energy
in a purely mathematical fashion
okay so what we did in the previous
slide here uh
by appealing to the original
transformation we have defined this
thing
and then it just so happened that we
were able to prove what we wanted to
what what the kind of expression that we
wanted to have here
but in certain textbooks uh
none of this is presented like this okay
the complementary energy
is discussed in a slightly different
fashion
by uh by
by taking recourse to the stress strain
relation rather the the plot associated
with the stress strain so what is done
is something like this
that in those textbooks they
they draw or they show uh
this kind of a stress-strain
relationship first of all
okay something like this so you
understand
that this is a linear relationship
between sigma and epsilon
so this is basically just hooke's law
and what they do is they say that if you
if you consider this zone okay if you
consider this zone
so this is
basically what is this strain energy
density
of course i have written it like u
naught uh but you understand that this
is uh the strain energy density
and what they say is that the
counterpart of this
area okay so if you
drop a horizontal from this point on
this
vertical axis then
this area
that is given by u naught dash
now of course for such a kind of linear
relationship
uh you understand that this is basically
a rectangle
and this is the diagonal so this area is
perfectly equal to this area
so of course for such a linear
relationship
this u naught and u naught dash are
perfectly
equal and of course in those textbooks
they also go on to say
that suppose we did not have
such a linear relationship
then also the same ideas would hold
suppose we had such a kind of
a non-linear relationship between sigma
and epsilon
then this part
would still continue to be the strain
energy density
this would still be the strain energy
density and
the counterpart of this
this would continue to be the
complementary energy density
and they of course point out that in
such a case as you as it is clearly
evident here
that u naught is not equal to u naught
dash
for the non-linear stress strain
relationship
now such a uh such a visual depiction
is very appealing to our understanding
but there is a problem here
the problem is that this kind
of a uh discussion
to motivate the the discussion of the
complementary energy or to introduce
the complementary energy density is a
little bit problematic because
uh these kinds of visual depiction
is only and only applicable for
one dimensional problems so what i mean
to say is that
only when you have the
a problem such that only one component
of strain and one component of stress is
important
okay so maybe for a very slender rod
which is under uniaxial tension
for such kind of problem this may be
all right this kind of discussion but
for a general enough problem
where you have multiple components of
stresses
and strains are contributing
then this visual depiction simply breaks
down
we cannot have such a such a naive and a
simplistic kind of
description it is good for a general uh
for a very very general kind of
introductory uh motivating example but
this cannot be
a general uh discussion of the topic
of complementary energy that is why it
is important
to really appeal to the general
mathematical
legendre transformation and to to
proceed from there
okay nevertheless uh there are some
important lessons
that we can extract out of even this
simplistic
thing which is to say that when we are
solving problems you will see that
uh indeed when our constitutive behavior
that is the relation between stresses
and strains is linear
uh then it really does not matter
whether we consider the complementary
energy density
or the strain energy density however
if our relationship is non-linear then
we simply
have to be very very careful with
considering
this kind of a complementary energy uh
complementary energy density
okay so we'll see the applications we'll
see that we'll see first of all
the development of the gastric illness
theorem and then uh we'll also
very much discuss the uh discuss the
solution of certain problems
uh both linear as well as non-linear
uh based on on the on the classic limits
theorem
all right so on that note i'll end this
lecture thank you very much